what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so as promised we are continuing on
our Green Lantern Sundays and at this
point we pick up with brightest day to
be honest with you guys after everything
that went on with blackest night the
fact that we had covered like everything
from the beginning of Green Lantern
rebirth with Hal Jordan back when he
first returned all the way up to you the
end of blackest night I was ready for a
break I was like I need a break from
Green Lantern's stuff which is one of
the reasons why we uploaded those full
story videos is because basically it
allowed a lot of people to play catch-up
to basically you know get caught back up
in case they'd forgotten about a lot of
the things that we had talked about so
kind of jump me back into this remember
blackest night in brightest day was
effectively a soft reboot for DC I mean
keep in mind
DC's only ever really done a hard reboot
twice in their publication history
crisis on Infinite Earths
and the new 52 remember those hard
reboots are basically designed that DC
asks you to pretend like they never
published characters before but with
brightest day it was kind of a softer
reboot because remember blackest night
was really just kind of every superhero
and every supervillain who had ever died
basically coming back by way of the
Black Lantern Rings of death and so that
was tantamount to DC taking every
superhero who ever died and then just
putting him on the board brightest day
and really the end of blackest night was
kind of the question who do we keep and
of course that's why DC chose 12 heroes
and 12 villains on each side
now of course brightest day picks up
with the aftermath of that it basically
says here are the heroes and villains
who have been resurrected from the dead
and we'll find out who they are as we
know as we continue to go through
brightest day but the whole idea behind
this was that it was basically saying
we're gonna choose these characters
based on whatever stories we think we
can tell whatever stories will basically
boost sales because well I wouldn't say
that DC was struggling financially in
the mid-2000s the whole idea behind
these stories was to basically continue
the the concept of grabbing characters
who existed either before crisis on
Infinite Earths or after crisis on
Infinite Earths who had basically died
and then finding a way to return them of
course this really comes as kind of like
an aftermath of sorts - like the death
of Superman different things like that
and we'll talk more about how that that
story influenced DC Comics and we get
into like Bart Allen explained different
things like that but this initially
picks up with Boston brand I remember
Boston brand appeared back in strange
adventures back in 1967 I don't know
exactly what comic what what issue it
was but Boston brand was you know
basically known as dead man and he was a
guy who was you know part of a high wire
act more or less so he'd been shot and
he fell to his death and of course the
entire basis behind his care
was tracking down the person who had
killed him but it allowed him the
ability to essentially jump from one
host body to the next with him basically
returning to life he is effectively a
kind of like this harbinger of the white
lantern in the sense that he's really
the only person right now
wielding a white Lantern ring now
remember at the end of my cast Knight
Sinestro was the first official White
Lantern in terms of the first person to
real the ring and use his absolute power
to defeat nekron and basically bring an
end to blackest night but with this
particular story Boston bran is kind of
serving this enigmatic purpose he
doesn't exactly know what it is he's
supposed to be doing one of the first
things this established is that the
white Lantern ring does have the ability
to resurrect the dead which of course we
end up finding out half way because of
the events of blackest night but also
because of the fact that he basically
revives a bird that had fallen to its
death but again for him it's very
mysterious here so the cool thing about
this is that because brightest day was
designed to be a soft reboot and because
a lot of people most likely picked up
with green lantern and read a lot of the
Green Lantern stories what this did is
it basically allowed BC to segue the
reader into the return of a lot of these
characters that they weren't necessarily
wildly familiar with or if they were
familiar with them it was really through
name only and so initially it jumps to
Arthur curry Aquaman who of course had
previously died and came back during
blackest night but the whole idea with
this is it really kind of toys with the
notion that a lot of these individuals
remember their time during blackest
night they remember being resurrected
from the dead they remember being black
lanterns and so it kind of creates his
inner turmoil to a degree because the
question becomes how do they deal with
that darker version of themselves
remember in a lot of ways they were just
kind of a passenger in their own body
the Black Lantern rings were the ones
that were the guiding force they were
controlling everything and so again for
Aquaman it's dealing with these various
scenarios
eobard thawne for example of course is
still alive and well we have the flash
who races off to meet digger Harkness
Captain Boomerang these are the kind of
things that take place but notice this
neither one who is a villain and died
and came back is gonna stay a villain
you know like digger Harkness for
example really kind of summarizes the
nature of Shawshank Redemption and the
fact that this banker who've been framed
for a murder he didn't commit
he was thrown in prison he was kind of
left there and he used the prison system
as his own means to effectively not only
free himself but to find a better life
than the one he had before and while
digger Harkness does kind of make this
illusion which indicates yeah like
eventually I'm gonna break out of here
and when I do I'm gonna make a better
life the question that's initially asked
by flash is is this a better criminal
life or a better good life and
response is the exact same thing that
Morgan Freeman's character offered in
the movie either get busy living or get
busy dying and so it's really one of
these things work it teases the idea
that Captain Boomerang is just kind of
tired of doing the same old thing if
being a villain led him to his own death
did why continue to be a villain this of
course follows up with the idea of
Hawkman and Hawkgirl the facts of these
characters have really just sort of died
and been resurrected thousands of times
over the course of their entire
existence but the cool thing about this
little tidbit here is it actually allows
us to grab the concept of Dark Knight's
metal and roll it into this story and
that's kind of the cool thing about this
that's one of the reasons why DC rebirth
is such an important line of
storytelling because it basically allows
you to take all these older stories that
happen before 2011 throw them back into
continuity as long as they're referenced
and then in turn basically say so like
this is what was going on in the
background while all that was happening
for example we know by virtue of dark
nights metal that Carter Hall was
exploring the mystery of in fettle
what's in metal where did it come from
you know we could take that entire
concept and throw it into brightest day
and say before the events of Carter
Hall's death he was exploring the nature
of in that'll and it works again you
know because of the fact that Boston
brand is basically being teleported from
one place to the next by the white
Lantern ring this is basically just
desire to kind of give us this tour of
sorts with regards to who's still alive
who's not still alive how they're
dealing with the fact that they've been
resurrected for example Maxwell Lord
Maxwell Lord having been one of the most
notable villains of DC's history was
basically a guy who uses mind-control to
effectively seize control of Superman he
had taken over brother I the global
satellite system developed by Batman to
monitor superheroes and in turn he was
killed by Wonder Woman and so because of
the fact that he's been resurrected he's
right back to his old schemes now of
course this spins out into a solo series
of its own which we probably won't cover
the story itself never really resonated
with me and it's not really crucial to
brightest a and now one of the most
welcomed resurrections when it came to
DC's right a state vent was the return
of Martian Manhunter
because Martian Manhunter was one of
these characters that really resonated
with a lot of fans in a lot of different
ways for Martian Manhunter he's always
been a man of two worlds of course a man
of Mars but he's also been a superhero
of Earth and so again that's a common
theme that you find when it comes to a
lot of different superheroes in DC and
that's one of the reasons why the
interpersonal relationships worked so
well I mean take for example Hal Jordan
Guy Gardner Jon Stewart and Kyle Anna
they're Green Lantern's and so while
they are superheroes on earth they're
torn between
loyalties as Green Lanterns they have a
far more important role to play in the
overall universe than they do on earth
and there have been times where they've
basically been called to choose you've
got a conflict on earth is easier
tension but you've also got a conflict
in the universe that requires the acts
of the entire Green Lantern Corps which
one do you choose and it creates a lot
of risks and it even goes as far as to
create animosity between the Green
Lantern's and the guardians of the
universe because they're basically being
told the goings on on earth are
insignificant in comparison to the
goings-on of the universe and so for
martian manhunter has always been this
idea that for him he has to basically
maintain this loyalty to his Martian
people but at the same time also ensure
that he's able to to maintain himself as
a productive member of the superhero
community on earth now one of the other
returns was a character by the name of
Jade and this was really interesting
because this was really DC and Geoff
Johns introducing the potential of a
love triangle with regards to Kyle
Rayner which is not something we've seen
all that often when it comes to the love
interest of Kyle Rayner for the most
part they've always been pretty linear
it's always been like you know this
characters introduced and then they die
and then that character is introduced
then they die has always kind of been
that way the Jade of course is the
daughter of Alan Scott the very first
Green Lantern and DC's publication
history now in truth following the
events of Infinite Crisis the
restoration of the multiverse DC
basically said Alan Scott was Green
Lantern from another universe but Jade
was at one point a love interest of Kyle
Rayner before cirrhotic not - of course
erratic not to being the daughter of
Sinestro because of the fact that sera
mnek does have feelings for Connor
Rayner and Kyle Rayner does have
feelings for a force erotic it did kind
of tease this idea that with Jade's
return Kyle Rayner is gonna be torn
between both and the stories of Kyle
Rayner in DC are nothing if not dramatic
you know focusing on the nature of his
character different things like that and
a lot of fans love it for that reason of
course this is nipped in the bud almost
immediately when Kyle Rayner basically
arrives to meet both Jade and Sarang
Ignacio says hey look Jade we were in
love once but that time is past you play
a very important role and you're needed
here but in truth my heart belongs to
cirrhotic not to at the moment and so it
is interesting because there's also
plays on the events of blackest night in
the sense that Jade really feels kind of
guilty for the fact that Ashley was used
as a Black Lantern
she killed various people have even
fought Kyle Rayner and used their love
against him different things like that
but again it's really kind of cool
because it feeds on the aftermath and
this whole block is my defense it
continues on with these trends of people
dealing with all these different
consequences in their own
emotional state and different things
like that now of course one of the most
notable aftermath of the event of
blackest night was the character of
firestorm and the reason why is because
for years it had always been Ronnie
Raymond and Professor Martin Stein and
it eventually became Jason Rusch and his
girlfriend and what DC ended up doing
here is they basically set because of
the fact that the character of firestorm
has always struggled in terms of
publication history which is to say
following the Martin Stein Ronnie
Raymond disbanding that the title never
really seemed to recover DC had this
idea to basically sit down and say well
then let's grab the characters of jason
rusch who does have a following and
let's grab the character of ronnie
raymond who has an established following
in the sense that he's the most well
known version of firestorm alongside
martin stein and let's combine them
together and it really kind of works by
virtue of the fact that you end up
having this irritation in the sense that
with ronnie raymond having been brought
back to life as a black lantern and then
in turn resurrected fully as a white
lantern jason rusch looks at him and
says you're the reason that my
girlfriend is dead and so it is
interesting because what we basically
end up getting is this kind of ronnie
raymond jason rusch version of firestorm
it was an experiment how will readers
respond to this what will be the
likelihood that they will find this to
be interesting and they will find this
to be intriguing and so again it's cool
because what this does is it really kind
of begins to wrap off the brightest a
number 0 issue by basically saying hey
look here's where things stand at the
moment you basically have Boston brand
who's being met with these visions and
these experiences of all these
individuals who have died and have
somehow come back to life but is hitting
home at the nature of this idea that
there are people like you know Green
Arrow for example who come back but that
they all serve a particular purpose what
that purpose is we won't find out
immediately instead what we end up doing
here is we pick up with the Green
Lantern tyent now the Green Lantern
tie-in is actually really really cool
because what this does is it really kind
of flushes out the second half of right
to stay in terms of the role of plays
and the reason why I say that is because
with brightest day 1/2 is dealing with
the aftermath of the various superheroes
and villains who will return to life the
other half is all the other Lantern
entities out there the orange Lantern
entity the Red Lantern entity all those
different things this really explores
all that stuff and really begins to
build on it now of course this also kind
of sees the return of the Trinity with
regards to Green Lantern's which is to
say Sinestro Carol Ferris and Hal Jordan
and it is kind of cool because what it
says is that in the aftermath of
blackest night that a sort of truce was
stuck we know with regards to Sinestro
you stay away we stay away and
everything is alright and everything
stays calm but with
sinestro his presence here is to
basically say there is a white Lantern
running around the planet earth right
now
and there's a white lantern central
power battery which means there's a
white Lantern ring the question we have
to ask is what does this mean what's the
significance of this this is cool
because it kind of sets the Green
Lantern core on the audience Daniel
really Hal Jordan a Sinestro fares on
this path of trying to figure out what's
going on with the white Lantern
exploring and expanding that whole
mythos now of course a lot of the other
things that go on to with regards to the
other lanterns for example st. Walker in
the Blue Lantern it's really just kind
of this idea that they're basically
laying to rest the bodies of those who
were just normal people and were used by
black Lantern's to you know increase the
Black Lantern number but there's also
basically picks up with the Green
Lantern Corps itself in the sense that
for some reason this not being fully
explained here Guy Gardner as well as
ganthet are basically meeting with
Atrocitus of the red lanterns and
striking some kind of a bargain and this
is cool because a whole idea behind this
is remembered when it comes to a trough
so does he has an absolute hatred for
the guardians of the universe in the
sense that the guardians of the universe
created the Manhunter robots the
Manhunter robots went awry they attack
Atrocitus his homeworld they obliterated
his family and he gave himself over to
pure rage forming the Red Lantern Corps
and so because of this whole thing the
idea is that this leads into a story
called the revolt of the Alpha lanterns
now in truth we're not gonna do that as
a separate video instead we're gonna
take revolt of the Alpha lanterns we're
just gonna kind of throw it in to the
main line of videos that we're doing
with brightest day so we'll just kind of
roll that into everything else that were
that we're sort of publishing here but
with the character of Gans that remember
ganthet and sayd are very particular
among the guardians of the universe
where the guardians of the universe are
like the first sentient beings in
existence more or less and they are the
ones who are responsible for creating
the Green Lantern Corps the guardians of
the universe had cast off their emotions
and so they are very much beings who are
logical so if you guys are coming from
Star Trek think of them in a lot of ways
like Vulcans and so because of this
ganthet and sayd are the ones who
basically looked at the prophecy of
blackest night in the sense that there
would be this war of light all these
Lantern course would go I'll go to war
with one another and where the other
guardians of the universe said that's
ridiculous it's a fear tactic we'll
write it out of the book of OM we'll
treat it like it never existed ganthet
and sayd we're a little wiser and said
no it does exist that prophecy is real
and we have to form the Blue Lantern
Corps to basically get them to unify as
opposed to fight against one another and
so there was basically the arrogance and
the hubris of the other guardians of the
universe
loud blackest night to reach its
crescendo and so as a result ganthet and
sayd are really kind of apart from the
other guardians of the universe they
basically don't really stand alongside
them and this really comes to fruition
when ganthet resigns his position among
the guardians of the universe and says
I'm just gonna become a Green Lantern
for sector zero and this is a really big
deal because what this means is that one
of the Guardians is no longer playing
their role instead ganthet in a lot of
ways has given up on the guardians of
the universe and basically said your
arrogance and your hubris led to the
blackest night event and so even if
there are times when you're simply not
going to adhere to what it is that goes
on with regards to the universe someone
needs to and there needs to be a
guardian that will protect the entire
sector and so because of this because
Gant that will be the protector of
sector 0 where the guardians of the
universe make their home it means you'll
likely be one of the most powerful Green
Lantern's out there because it's
basically all the power of a guardian
which is astronomical and scale enough
to dwarf people like Superman and then
in turn amplify that power with a Green
Lantern ring now this also deals with
the events of you know fall out with
regards to everybody sort of envisioning
the events of blackest night and so on
and so forth but even one of the guys
one of these Green Lantern's is
basically just kind of whisked away you
know rookie Lantern and Pawar I think
it's how you pronounce it what kind of
role car I think it makes sense the H is
silent we'll just assume that it's
silent but it is kind of intriguing
because again all this really deals with
the idea that the Alpha lanterns really
seem to be revolting seem to be
expanding their number and keep in mind
the Alpha lanterns were created
explicitly by the guardians of the
universe yet another instance of them
really kind of giving way to their own
arrogance and their own hubris in the
sense that because the fact that the
Sinestro Corps war basically saw the
Sinestro Corps formed by Thoth Sinestro
going to war against the Green Lantern
Corps the Green Lantern's being given
the ability to kill in order to
basically face off against the Sinestro
Corps it led to one of their member
killing a Sinestro Corps member who was
unarmed she of course was put on trial
and of course she was found guilty and
exiled from the Green Lantern's but in
response to this the Guardian said there
has to be an aspect of the Green Lantern
Corps that police's the Green Lantern's
and that's why the Alpha lanterns were
made the problem with this is that as
far as the guardians are concerned the
Alpha lanterns are part machine more or
less and part sentient being and so in
their mind the Alpha lanterns can't make
mistakes and so what this does is it
really sort of puts the Alpha lanterns
in a position that if they chose to
revolt that the Guardians wouldn't mess
thoroughly realized what was going on
initially that's really kind of what's
being done here in the sense that the
tea made of rock are you know the
lantern that went missing by the Alpha
lanterns is searching for his partner
only to find out he's been converted
into an alpha lantern and the Alpha
lanterns themselves are basically
bolstering their numbers so again a lot
of themes coming out of the first part
of brightest day basically sit in the
stage before a lot of these storylines
that really sort of begin to evolve and
grow and different things like that okay
so as we continue on with our stories on
brightest day we're kind of at an
impasse here and this is one of the
reasons why I wanted to cover the first
part of brightest day in the sense that
we basically had like all these things
going on you know he had the the main
brightest a story and we had you know
the Green Lantern Corps and we had the
Green Man Green Lantern title and the
reason why is because brightest day is
not like blackest night right like
blackest night for the most part it did
follow the escapades of these characters
like Green Lantern Corps Kyle Rayner and
got Gardner different things like that
it did follow them too you know with
regards to their escapades but it all
kind of segue into the conclusion of
blackest night with regards to brightest
day it doesn't necessarily work that way
the stories of Green Lantern the stories
of the Green Lantern Corps of emerald
warriors those actually segue into a
story called the war of the Green
Lantern's out with regards to brightest
day the main event itself which spanned
about 24 issues and it was a twice
monthly series running for a whole year
that actually details the return of 12
heroes and twelve villains so we can do
that but if all people really care about
which I surmise all you guys are really
interested in is just like you know the
Green Lantern entities and the the
various Lantern cores that are out there
that's really just like the main Green
Lantern story that that's really all
that details are really the the biggest
emphasis of all that kind of stuff now
again we can kind of play it by ear and
we can just sort of sort of shoot for it
I mean because of the fact of the the
Green Lantern tie-ins quote-unquote for
lack of a better word for brightest a
are pretty limited in the sense that
they run from like 53 to 62 there's
ample room for us to basically just
leave out the main brightest day event
and in cover the Green Lantern comics
cover Green Lantern Corps and cover
emerald warriors and kind of go from
there but for the sake of this video
we're gonna stick with the Maine Green
Lantern story to give you guys an idea
of what to expect if we were to go this
route and what this does is it initially
just kind of picks up with really just
some guys being pretty shady in a subway
just giving people a hard time and like
you
robbing folks stuff like that when
they're suddenly met with the arrival of
deck star now deck star is one of these
characters than a lot of like a lot of
lantern fans absolutely love they love
deck star and he is a great character
he's a cat he's a Red Lantern cat and
it's pretty awesome like he's pretty
brutal that the story he has like his
story is pretty sad too like I believe
it was that he was adopted by a woman
and then some people broke in and like I
think they ended up ending her life and
the result was that our Dexter was kind
of cast out that so people grabbed him
and they're gonna like throw him over a
bridge when he suddenly met with a Red
Lantern ring and then just like goes
ballistic and like kills the guys who
were trying to take him out and then
just kind of goes from there it's pretty
hardcore it's pretty brutal and it's
really sad but it's actually pretty
brutal
now the other half of this is that it
also comes with the arrival of Atrocitus
now I remember
Atrocitus never really left Earth I mean
he kind of did but he's sort of been
bouncing back and forth with regards to
the events following blackest night and
this sense of blackest night really kind
of brought all these different Lantern
course to earth itself because that's
where the battle against the black
Lantern's was taking place so it made
sense they're all kind of segue into
that one location but the whole idea
here is that this focus is really in a
lot of ways on the kind of aftermath of
the White Lantern Corps that's why I say
we kind of bounce back and forth a
little bit in the sense of the main
brightest a story basically said hey
look at the end of blackest night
Sinestro basically became the first
White Lantern after discovering the
White Lantern entity and then suddenly a
white lantern battery of hara battery
appeared and no one's been able to lift
it it's almost like this sword in the
stone kind of situation in the sense
that no one could really pick it up so
the initial response of like Carol
Ferris you know as a star sapphire and
Sinestro and Hal Jordan is what we'll
each try it in turn and we'll see what
happens now of course in the attempt to
pick this up what they end up getting is
this kind of feedback of source whereby
the lantern really kind of shows them
these characters that have come back
these characters that are basically we
emerged you know Aquaman for example was
brought back as a result of blackest
night Martian Manhunter different things
like that and again we talked about that
in the main blackest night story that
black is not in brightest day or
basically designed to be soft reboots it
was a way for DC to come back and say
okay so here are these characters that
have died in some former fashion over
the course of our publication history
after we first rebooted in 1985 and we
want to bring some of these characters
back and so we're gonna use blackest
night to do it they're all gonna come
back as zombies and then at the end of
blackest night the white Lantern is
going to quote
quote cure people and those that we want
to keep will return to normal
those that we don't want to keep we'll
just go back to being dead and it served
its purpose and the since only a handful
of people came back
but the biggest front of this and the
most significant part of this for you
know Hal Jordan and for Sinestro and for
Carol Ferris is they're basically shown
the entities and this is a very big deal
remember this is all brand-new stuff or
at least at the time it was being
written by Geoff Johns it was brand-new
stuff this stuff never existed before
it's not like this is you know
retreading water of the Green Lantern
mythos this is all new there had never
been entities that existed before I mean
even the concept of parallax that was
just something that Hal Jordan called
himself originally it wasn't until geoff
johns took over the Green Lantern title
that he said no no what actually
happened was that how Jordan was
possessed by the parallax fear entity
and that's where that whole thing comes
from what we end up finding out here is
the predator belongs to the star
sapphires Ophidian belongs to the orange
lanterns Adara belongs to the blue
lanterns
you know proselyte belongs to the to the
Indigo tribe the butcher of course one
of the more popular ones for the red
lanterns you know this is the whole the
whole thing we're basically saying that
these are the entities that represent
that aspect of the emotional spectrum
remember the emotional spectrum is just
kind of like an amalgamation of things
which is to say the emotional aspect of
fear is a result of everybody in the
universe having felt fear at some point
along the line
same thing with rage and love and and so
on and so forth all those different
things now what we do here is we
sidetrack for a second and we actually
pick up with ion we pick up with sodium
yacht and sodam yacht was actually a
character that we really kind of
explored a bit but didn't do a whole lot
with in the you know in the aftermath of
like Sinestro Corps war different things
like that if you guys remember that far
back to our videos so dumb yacht is a
daksa might you know essentially what
this means is that he is basically a
Kryptonian without actually being a
Kryptonian and the reason why was
because again you know at some point
along the line in the early history of
Krypton's existence some Kryptonians
left they basically walked away from the
planet and they settled somewhere else
they settled on a planet called axon and
for the most part they just sort of
existed in isolation they just didn't
really deal with anything on the outside
anybody who showed up to their planet
was usually executed in order to keep
their existence secret so dumb yacht was
a kid who basically looked to the Stars
and wanted to explore the spaceways and
this all really came to a head when he
was offered the opportunity to be a
Green Lantern but it was essentially a
way for DC to answer the question what
would happen if Superman became a Green
Lantern without actually using Superman
just because of the fact that
his own stories going on at the time and
really a lot of the really the editors
for Superman
you know wouldn't let that happen so
what we got was sodium yacht he was
basically kind of brought back and
introduces the idea that he is you know
if exposed to a Yellow Sun will have all
the powers of Superman and it was cool
for what it was it was it was pretty
interesting in fact there was a point in
time when Daxton was on the verge of
being totally obliterated in the resort
area with Sinestro Corps members
attacking the planet different things
like that
sodium meowth arrived to this home
planet he transformed the red sun into a
yellow sun and gave all of his people
powers the aftermath to this was that
when his people started taking to the
spaceways they started basically
punishing anybody who wasn't liked then
and so the result is that it allowed for
you know soda yahoo had basically been
kind of sitting in stasis to essentially
go back to being his normal self in the
sense that some guardian of the universe
basically comes along and in turn he
Yanks him back you know brings him out
of this star and returns them back to
life more or less in the sense that the
star goes back to being a red star soda
meowth emerges and basically they
removed the ion entity now I remember
that was something that we talked about
with regards to like Kyle Rayner and it
was really one of the first times that
we had seen that that in the history of
DC Comics it was essentially this idea
that Kyle Rayner had possessed a couple
different varying levels of power but he
simply just called himself ion this
again was another change by Geoff Johns
in the sense that Geoff Johns came along
and he said actually it's not just the
Kyle Rayner too started calling himself
ion one day what he is is he's basically
host for the entity of the Green Lantern
Corps basically the Whale entity called
ion the guardians of the universe put
that entity in him should they all go
extinct Karina will be the one to bring
them back that was the whole basis
behind it now of course the Sinestro
Corps war that entity was yanked out of
him by Thal Sinestro and replaced with
parallax and in turn the entity was
placed inside of soda yacht and they
literally just kind of been there ever
since up until right now but again it's
a way to sort of wrap these threads up
to kind of bring these things to an end
and say okay things are back to their
status quo now and this since this Odom
yacht is just back to being a Green
Lantern presumably with the same powers
of Superman but he's no longer a host
for the Green Lantern entity out there
and so if what seems to be going on here
is that someone is going through and
capturing the entities that's
essentially what's happening they take
the Green Lantern entity of Aion away
from Sao Tome yacht did the same thing
with a parallax entity and it looks like
they're hunting for all the others for
the Blue Lantern entity in the orange
lantern and Red Lantern
so on and so forth that looks to be
what's basically going on here and so
the result is that when the question is
asked by Hal Jordan really kind of more
you know rhetorical than anything else
what are we doing what do you know what
it what is the this whole ring asking of
us the ring simply responds by saying
you know
Atrocitus will help you find the
entities so that's what this turns into
is basically a race to locate the
entities and it's cool because what this
means is it gives us a kind of tour of
this whole thing a tour of the expansion
of the green lantern and the you know
really the overall Lantern core mythos
and that's one of the reasons why the
Green Lantern story is so significant is
because even if you have events that
kind of cross over to a degree for the
most part you can walk away from the
main event like you know like right a
snake and focus only on Green Lantern
and it's a self-contained story for the
most part that allows you to just kind
of continue on with what you've read
running all the way up through like
Sinestro Corps war and blackest night
without really having feel you know
feeling lost or anything like that or
dumping all your money into comics and
of course for Atrocitus himself he's
doing the exact same thing he's always
done where he's basically using you know
blood prophecy to either see the future
or something like that and this instance
the question is where are the entities
located now of course with the arrival
of Hal Jordan and then Sinestro and
Carol Ferris it does present kind of a
cool situation because immediately a
fight breaks out which is exactly what
we would expect you know it's one of
those things where it's kind of come to
be the standard like hey Atrocitus we
need your help attack you know he just
immediately starts attacking everybody
and you know a great big huge conflict
takes place now of course in the middle
of all this the group is basically met
with the arrival of lobo now a little
bit of history here
logo made his debut back in like
omegamin number three in June of 1983
and he was created by Roger Stifler and
it's pretty common knowledge by now
pretty much you know exceedingly well
known Lobo was designed to be a parody
of Wolverine that's really what he is
and a lot of this was because of the
fact that Wolverine was exceedingly
over-the-top to a degree and because of
that DC really kind of countered by
saying okay well like let's make Lobo
let's just have a guy who just rides
around on a motorcycle he's almost
completely indestructible and he's
basically just a bounty hunter that's
really what he is now making him a
bounty hunter as far as I'm aware that
was originally Roger Stifler's idea
because what it would do is it would
allow for the character of Lobo to just
kind of appear and disappear in DC
Comics having him be a bounty hunter
means that he would just like show up
based on a
entourage so you know for whatever
reason somebody put a contract out on
Superman
you'd see you Lobo or Superman fight it
would usually be an even battle and then
Globo would just leave and that would be
the end of that and then he wouldn't
show up for another you know six months
to a year something along those lines so
is actually pretty eloquent in terms of
how they decided to roll his character
in and what they decided to do with them
but the other half of this is that we
also deal with you know logo basically
having really being here for the purpose
of taking out Atrocitus and this works
and it's really really interesting
because when it comes to the character
of Atrocitus we know that he's gone
through and just committed like all
these heinous acts we would expect this
to happen not only that is actually a
pretty cool battle because remember Lobo
has gone toe-to-toe with Superman on a
multitude of occasions and so seeing him
face off against Atrocitus is really
like watching Superman battle Atrocitus
without the moral compass of Superman
the willingness to hold back instead
it's just a matter of hey there's a
bounty on you and like one way or
another I aim to collect like I'm
getting paid and it is cool it's really
intriguing the problem with this is that
Hal Jordan is told by the White Lantern
Atrocitus has your mission and so it's
basically this idea that they have to
ally themselves with Atrocitus now I
remember this goes against everything
Hal Jordan stands for in almost every
conceivable way I mean if we had to take
the character of Atrocitus and the Red
Lanterns and we had to ask the question
what's their purpose in DC their purpose
is to destroy the Green Lantern's and to
destroy the guardians of the universe
why because the Guardians of the
Universe originally made the Manhunter
robots to police the universe the
Manhunter robots were wanna try and they
obliterated basically everything in one
sector of the universe and that resulted
in Atrocitus is rage really kind of
building up and him forming the Red
Lanterns and so because of the fact that
his family was obliterated he basically
has a vendetta against the guardians of
the universe because the Green Lantern's
were created by the guardians in the
aftermath of the Manhunters as a way to
basically improve on their idea of
policing the universe the Red Lanterns
in turn hate the Green Lantern's because
they're basically agents of the
guardians of the universe and so again
that's one of the reasons why for Hal
Jordan is it's very much reluctant in
his mind he'd rather see Atrocitus just
die but it does make for a pretty cool
battle because with lobo being so
durable
well you have like fall Sinestro who
conjures your crates these constructs in
attempt to take out Lobo Lobo does kind
of smashes through them and even hits
Sinestro with his own constructs and it
is cool because then you have hero Faris
who tries to encase them as a star
I usually do in case of being in there
energy and then in turn try to move them
towards love and and logo just breaks
out of the entire construct now in truth
if we were going to read between the
lines here we could probably deduce the
fact that this is really Jeff John's
bringing the character of Lobo in and
saying hey I don't know if you guys are
interested but here's how someone like
Lobos pants against all the lanterns and
like they don't stand a chance of course
in response to this you of course have
Dex star fighting the dog of Lobo and of
course Hal Jordan basically steps up and
says look I hate to be the one to have
to do this but you you got to keep your
hands off at rasa's now remember it's
not like Lobo is new to Hal Jordan how
Jordan is fought against Lobo on a
multitude of occasions alongside the
Justice League alongside Superman he's
well versed in how powerful Lobo is and
so notice this code Jordan doesn't
really like skirt by he's not like oh
well you know Lobo is here whatever you
know we'll ignore him and then we'll go
about our business it's no dude Lobos
here man like this is a big deal now of
course because of the fact that it
really is just kind of overwhelming odds
I mean it's the star sapphires it's the
Green Lantern you know the whole nine
yards at this point it really kind of
breaks down to you okay
Lobo can't win against all these guys at
once especially considering that all
Sinestro Carol Ferris and Hal Jordan
have allied themselves with Atrocitus so
the result is that Lobo basically just
leased now what we would expect here is
that Lobo would return eventually
because normally when a contract is
taken out and someone hires Lobo to take
out some person Lola will keep coming
back unless somebody like talked him out
of it
unless the story just calls for him to
not come back I don't know but the fact
remains here that it is an intriguing
situation because ultimately Atrocitus
just kind of leaves you know he just
says whatever of course the lanterns
will have to follow after him in order
to gain their mission what we also end
up finding out here is that this was
basically a task that was bestowed on
Lobo by Atrocitus himself that Atrocitus
took out a hit on himself any hired Lobo
to collect that bounty so the reason for
this and the motivation for this isn't
initially explained here in fact we
don't really find out in this story it's
just for whatever reason Atrocitus hired
Lobo to take him out so that you know
how Jordan and Carol fares and install
Sinestro would come to his aid now in
truth this is probably a trough siddhis
if I'm gonna be you know brazen here
being a little socially awkward that's
probably what this is instead of just
saying hey look guys we've had our
issues in the past but we need to work
together to find the entities you know
it's I can't
you know that I need your help so I'm
going to take a hit out on myself and
we're gonna have to work together and
then you guys will be my friends you
know and then we'll go forward as not
being enemies that kind of seems to be
what's going on here very socially
awkward very weird ah a normal human
being would just say hey I need your
all's help but you know it is kind of
intriguing and it is kind of funny
because again you know we'll find out
what the motivation of Atrocitus is as
we go on into this whole Green Lantern
arc but it is cool because what this
does is it leaves us with the idea that
lobo basically took a Red Lantern ring
for himself that at some point along the
line Lobo may very well return as a Red
Lantern which is cool okay so I just
want to say this before we actually jump
into this video the colony is so good
the show do the show with like Sawyer
from lost oh my god do this show so
amazing cuz you guys aren't watching
that you guys are sorely missing out so
you guys need to go check that out it's
actually on Netflix for the first two
seasons anyway so we're continuing on
with our whole thing on on brightest day
and the general consensus really seemed
to be that a lot of people really just
enjoyed the idea of like the lantern
entity so a lot of people didn't really
care about like the twelve heroes and
villains that came back and what people
say I want to know about the Green
Lantern usually what they're saying is I
want to know about the Green Lantern
mythos I don't really want to know about
the entities and that's kind of a that's
a reasonable stance to take I mean it's
not unreasonable at all so we're gonna
go ahead and kind of continue on this
trend now the cool thing is that in the
last video we basically kind of covered
the idea that according to this newly
created white lantern really the newly
established white Lantern if someone or
something is running around and
capturing all these different entities
that exists out there with regards to
the various Lantern cores now this is
intriguing because this is basically
geoff johns way of setting in motion
this kind of indication of what the
various entities are about and this is
why i say this part of the story really
this part of the Green Lantern mythos is
probably the most important stuff until
we get to like wrath of the first
Lantern this really expands it more than
anything else and that's the nature of
this I mean we talked about that when we
first jumped into this and we started
the Green Lantern rebirth stories and
like you know how Jordan wanted all that
kind of stuff we said as time goes on
this mythos will start to expand by huge
amounts and we've seen that I mean you
had Sinestro Corps war which basically
eliminated the rules the Green Lantern's
couldn't kill people so now they can we
also had the Sinestro Corps which
brought about this other Lantern Corps
that previously didn't exist now we have
the Red Lanterns and we have the star
sapphires and we have the blue lanterns
all these
and have kind of spawned out there the
white lanterns black lanterns and that's
the whole idea behind this what this
does is it takes the next step it's like
math two plus two equals four now it's
time for us to multiply two times two
which still equals four but the fact
remains here that it is cool because
we're taking the next steps what we're
doing is we're saying okay so we have
these Lantern course and these Lantern
cores basically draw their energy from
the emotional spectrum so what's inside
the emotional spectrum that's what this
whole thing builds on and that's the
cool thing now this all goes back to ion
right the ion entity that was a way for
Geoff Johns to kind of come back when he
took over the green lantern line of
stories and to say well when Kyle Rayner
became Allah became ion he wasn't just
ion I mean it was a name at the time but
he's basically the torchbearer the Green
Lantern entity ion the representation of
the Green Lantern course energy that's
been thrown into Kyle Rayner eventually
was removed but that's where that whole
thing came from it there are these
beings out there that represent the some
totality of what if part of the
emotional spectrum is and so in this
instance what we do here is we basically
pick up with Hector Hammond now remember
Hector Hammond for the most part has
kind of been a background character in a
lot of what's been going on in the Green
Lantern mythos and rightfully so the
whole idea was to take these characters
who had long since stood in the Green
Lantern landscape and to keep them you
know fresh in the minds of fans who have
been reading Green Lantern for a long
time but to also say yes we have this
great idea we want to keep the stuff
that works but we also want to add to
this we want to build on top of this now
Hector Hammond of course as we've
discussed before has been a longtime
villain of Hal Jordan at least had been
for quite a while but the idea behind
Hector Hammond is he was just a guy who
has telepathic powers and there's simply
this idea that his powers are being kept
in check he's being more or less kept
hidden and his origin goes into green
lantern rebirth which we discussed you
guys are welcome to check that video
down in the description but the issue
with this is that following the
conclusion of blackest night we
essentially had the parallax entity take
off and presumably attach itself to
Hector Hammond or at least that seemed
to be the case now that's not actually
what's going on here instead Hector
Hammond is hearing a voice from another
person he's hearing a voice from another
being that's just kind of floating out
there and ultimately it says look you've
got friends everywhere so on and so
forth and it essentially sucks like all
these rats onto these guards and
effectively takes these guards out but
what it does is it allows for the escape
of Hector Hammond now the funny thing
about this too is we also get to revisit
the character of Larfleeze and I
remember more flea
is like the comedic relief in a lot of
ways but but don't be mistaken like
don't be fooled while he is funny
Larfleeze is a beast
he's an absolute monster and we'll find
out just how insanely powerful he is as
we go forward into the future of these
Green Lantern stories but the funny
thing about this is remember the
blackest night event saw all these
different lanterns kind of culminating
on to earth the heads of the Lantern
Corps so that's really kind of what
happened and after blackest night was
over we immediately went into brightest
day with the formation of the sea of
this white Lantern and so it was really
like look before you guys could take off
you guys have a task you need to perform
you guys need to find who's who's
kidnapping and taking all these entities
and so it is kind of cool because what
is up happening is there's basically a
scene that's called you know there's
this huge issue going on where a cop
says look man there's all this craziness
happening around here and when Hal
Jordan is like hey does it look like
this guy he shows him a picture of
Larfleeze and the cops like yep that's
exactly who he is and then we basically
end up having Hal Jordan traveling over
to meet Larfleeze and Larfleeze is just
hoarding everything
it's like trees and like cars everything
that you can imagine he's been taking
like pinball machines and sweets the
whole nine yards because rubric
Larfleeze is driven by greed that's
that's the motivating factor avarice
that's all he wants to do is just get as
much as he can mine mine mine mine mine
what's crazy here is that Larfleeze is
trying to acquire as much stuff as
possible and Larfleeze has discovered
commercials now in discovering
commercials Larfleeze has discovered
that earth houses a magical being who
only goes around once a year and gives
people their heart's desire yes I'm
talking about Santa Claus Larfleeze
believes Santa Claus is real and
Larfleeze is like I'm writing a letter
to a letter to Santa
because he'll give me my he'll give me
everything that I want and and and like
oh I'll have everything that I could
ever want to have and it's almost kind
of funny because how Jordan has to break
the news to Larfleeze that Santa's not
real but but again this is important
because from here it really kind of
starts to branch out into things it
starts to grow into things what we end
up having here is basically end up
learning that Ophidian the
representation that the orange lantern
entity is housed inside of Larfleeze
lantern which is one of the reasons why
he's so powerful is because every facet
of the orange lantern concept is housed
directly within the lantern of more
fleas and he basically mainline
that power into himself and so because
he's just insane because it's like
having one green lantern that has all
the powers of the green lanterns and you
can just use all that power to his own
ends make almost indestructible
constructs things like that the problem
with this is that we're met with the
arrival of Hector Hammond who at route
basically swallows the orange Lantern
ring of Larfleeze and woody does he's
effectively empowered by the Athenian
entity and becomes this kind of living
embodiment of Ophidian now the other
half of this is it also hits at things
like a person who's basically being
tracked by the predator does walk which
is basically out there you know in
Montana with regards to the Red Lanterns
I mean all these things that are going
on in terms these entities they're all
for the most part housed on earth and so
as a result when Hector Hammond
basically becomes ophidians his initial
response is I want to find Carol Ferris
now this is interesting here because
it's basically greed remember greed is
the overriding factor and it really is
intriguing because in this scenario what
we're actually gonna find is there's a
little bit of overlap when it comes to
greed and when it comes to love
oftentimes the two cross paths and it
could be very difficult to differentiate
between which one is motivated by the
other at this point we switch over to a
two xamarin with the star sapphires now
remember one thing I want to I want to
kind of reiterate here is the nature of
the star sapphires because this actually
ties in to what's happening at the
moment the idea to star sapphires is
they are basically women who had broken
away from the original guardians of the
universe and they just kind of gone off
on this you know escapade and kind of
gone through this hole itself
discovering journey different things
like that but they had basically
discovered the ancient bodies of a
Hawkman and Hawk woman and because of
the fact that Hawkman and Hawk woman are
destined to basically you know be born
in physical form and then meet each
other fall in love and then die and in
the process repeats itself
they represent undying love the idea
that from now until the end of the
universe they will always be destined to
die and then be reborn and then meet and
fall in love and die again and so what
the the star sapphires did is they use
that concept of love as the foundation
for the energy of the star sapphires now
they use that to kind of create their
central power battery so on and so forth
but the issue with this is that because
of the events of blackest night and
brightest day Hawkman and Hawk woman
have been reborn and so what that means
is that their bodies are just kind of
laying there their their undying love
can't be used as a source of energy
anymore because they're alive now
they're actually out there now so their
corpses can't really be used as a source
of energy because there's nothing left
and so the result is that it seems as
this star sapphire central power battery
is basically eroding because there's no
more energy left for it to use and so
the idea is to say we have to find the
predator we have to find the entity of
these star sapphires the entity of love
and then confine it within the central
power battery and use that as a source
of energy now at this point we pick up
with Las Vegas of course SimCity I'm
really excited because I'm going to Las
Vegas in like four days and I've never
been before
so I'm really really I'm really excited
I'll probably post pictures on on
Instagram make sure you guys follow me
on instagram at commerce explained and
make sure you follow me on twitter at
comments explained because I'll probably
post pictures there too but the fact
remains that with regards to Carol
Ferris she's basically instructed by
Queen agapo of the zamarons
look the predator is on earth like your
assignment is to find the predator to
basically find a way to contain the
predator and bring the part at her back
as it was kind of cool because what we
end up doing is picking up with this guy
who's basically obsessed with this girl
now here's the interesting thing is that
this really is just a genuine obsession
because what is up happening here is
this guy Abraham point is met by the
predator and the predator simply says
you feel great love for a girl that
you've never met so let's change that
and so literally the part of their bonds
with this guy and then takes off to meet
this girl now this is a little bit I
mean if if I'm gonna go out on a limb
here and I'm gonna be a little bit
dangerous and possibly throw some words
in the mouth of Jeff Jones this is like
a life lesson on love because it's the
question of what happens if you're in
love with someone but you never actually
act on it and you don't really talk to
them are you in love or are you
infatuated but before we get into that
there's this massive panic that's going
on in in Las Vegas everything's kind of
going crazy
kara Ferris goes to check it out and
Larfleeze is there now why is this
hilarious because he's celebrating the
fact that he's in Vegas and Larfleeze
has discovered an all-you-can-eat buffet
so he's this he's ecstatic because it's
like you could have as much as you want
and he's like yes I can have as much as
I want which of course this is Chinese
food that would definitely be amazing
anything else well you know it kind of
depends on what they serve but as we all
know Chinese buffets are the best
buffets they are they are so good I'm
getting hungry for Chinese buffet right
now but in any event getting back into
our discussion about love you know our
philosophical perspective about this
this is why this is so cool is because
for a lot of people out there
the idea of
almost seems like this sort of concept
that exists in some other dimensional
realm it's a thing they know of and it's
a thing other people have somehow been
able to acquire but it's a thing that
they themselves have not been able to
gain it's like this intangible concept
it's smoke slipping through their
fingers and so in a lot of ways people
just kind of watch from afar but they
never actually take that step and never
actually say anything and that's what's
going on with this guy that's what I
want a brand point that he was truly you
know he at least he believed that he was
genuinely in love with this girl the
irony of it all is she doesn't know who
he is and he did you know he knows her
by some means it's never really explored
but he's been watching her for quite
some time and so it's basically that
idea that being in that kind of a
mindset this silly saying like I'm in
love with that person but never taking
this step to make your feelings known is
wildly unhealthy because it puts you in
a very negative mindset because at that
point then your imagination begins to
run wild and instead of simply and you
know envisioning all these flights of
fantasy about the kind of life you can
have together
well then suddenly it starts to become
unhealthy and as hawaii's as she's
saying anything to me is it because she
doesn't like me well she doesn't like me
what's wrong with me what's so messed up
about me that that she doesn't like me
and then suddenly it stops being you
being okay with yourself and it turns
into you there everything about me is
wrong I've got to fix myself I've got to
make myself better all because of the
fact that you never went out there and
said anything and I can say that because
I've been there
I've been down that road before and I
know how unhealthy that mindset can be
and that's the cool thing there's all
these different little philosophical
lessons that you can draw from geoff
johns writing where he kind of says hey
look this is the struggle of life the
struggle of life is mustering up the
courage to say something and so that's
the idea behind this now of course with
Carol Farris his mind says she figures
this out almost immediately she
basically says look this guy believes he
feels love and that's why he's basically
being taken over by the predator is
because he genuinely believes he loves
that girl but he doesn't know what love
is
but everyone wants to be loved everybody
in some former fashion wants to be told
I love you by someone who's not a member
of their family they want to had that
kind of butterfly on your stomach
floating through the air they want to
have that giddiness that excitement you
know that kind of honeymoon phase when
it comes to being in a relationship and
because everyone wants that all this guy
wants is to feel loved even if it's only
for a momentary second and that's what
Carol Ferris gives him how she kisses
him doesn't really give him much more
than that but you know she kisses him
and he feels loved and in doing so the
predator was removed in his entirety you
know and as a result it doesn't really
bond itself to Carol Ferris so much as
she grabs a predator and they basically
travel to
now the initial reaction here and this
is kind of the cool concept is Carol
Ferris as argument is look these
entities are a byproduct of the being
that wields them which is to say they
take whatever experience they've had
with that being and that starts to
become a part of who they are the
predator being a violent creature is
because of the fact that it's its entire
concept is mired in violence if the base
is behind the Predators existence is the
basis behind the star sapphires
existence and the basis behind the star
sapphires existence is the death and
rebirth of Hawkman and Hawk woman well
then all this thing really knows is
death all it really knows is like
destruction and then love those two
concepts kind of mingled together what
it needs to know is true love it needs
to know what love really is it needs to
understand that concept and the only way
for that to happen is for it to bond to
a human host and so initially the others
a morons are simply like no this can't
happen like this thing has to be the
source of our central power battery
otherwise it can't function but notice
this Carol Ferris has responses that's
not true look at the Green Lantern's the
Green Lantern's don't throw ion in the
the central power battery like the
central power battery for the Green
Lantern's functions strictly on
willpower all the willpower that exists
out there in the universe is basically
kind of drawn in and used by the central
power battery and spread throughout the
other Green Lantern's there's no reason
to believe the zamarons can't be the
same way that the central power battery
of the star sapphires will function
based on all the love that exists in the
universe and if it does then there's no
need for the predator entity to be
bonded to the central power battery that
doesn't have to be part of the equation
this is actually really cool because
what this does is it sets the stage for
the possibility that Carol Ferris or
anybody out there could become a host
for the for the predator entity
effectively making them into a star
sapphire Jeff Jones is basically
grabbing all these different entities
bringing them in and then saying they
exist outside of the central power
battery ie anybody can use them anybody
can wield them anybody can become one of
them if they're subjected to you know
possession by this entity but it's cool
because it's all this world building
stuff it's expanding on these things and
helping to sort of grow these different
ideologies and so on and so forth but
again when it comes to brightest day you
have the main brightest day event but
the Green Lantern tie-ins are actually
more interesting there are actually a
lot more intriguing in terms of how
brightest day comes together you know
the one thing I hate the most about
having the flu is my schedule gets all
thrown off and so it's like okay like
I am in no condition to record so
whatever videos we have online those
videos are going out and only in care if
it matches the schedule or not like it's
it's it's crazy like it is it is rough
but we are finally back on track we're
finally back on our schedule we're doing
our Green Lanterns on Sundays and again
we're picking up with a green lantern
line of stories as part of brightest day
and I'm actually I mean I'm gonna be
honest here guys I'm actually like Green
Lantern more than I like the main
brightest a story now a lot of that
again is because of the fact that
brightest day was designed to detail the
12 heroes 12 villains or what have you
they came back to life after the events
of blackest night but if those are
characters that you were never really
interested in in the first place the
main story probably wouldn't intrigue
you that much and so again because the
fact that that Green Lantern focuses on
the lantern entities this is where all
the world-building is and I remember
we've basically fleshed out a couple
things the first is that parallax the
yellow lantern entity the entity of the
Sinestro Corps the being that possessed
Hal Jordan during the events of Emerald
Twilight that was only the first entity
that we knew of and there were so many
others to go over there was also the
entity of the orange lantern that was
basically that was essentially possessed
by Hector Hammond who is one of the most
notable enemies of Hal Jordan now at the
point right now Hector Hammond is still
out there he's not been captured off
panel or anything like that in terms of
like how Jordan and those guys he's just
still floating around out there and
that's gonna be kind of a focal point of
this story to a degree especially when
it comes to the character of of
Larfleeze but at this moment what we
actually end up doing here is picking up
with a prison in Montana this
effectively just kind of been totally
obliterated and destroyed and the way is
described here is that there was
something that was akin to a bull I just
kind of ran through this whole thing and
tore everything out that basically just
sort of riffing up the prison to pieces
and all that kind of good stuff
and where the cops are kind of trying to
figure out what's going on and where
they're analyzing the situation and
they're talking about how to take it out
what is up happening as one of them
describes it as a being that's made of
like fire or something along those lines
and then Atrocitus shows up alongside
Sinestro and says that's because it's
not fire it's pure rage now remember
after the events of blackest night well
we kind of had where all these leaders
of the Lantern course who showed up on
earth to fight necron the leader of the
black Lantern's and following necrons
defeat we basically had the white
lantern that showed up and because the
white Lantern was there what it meant is
that everybody was kind of curious about
it at the same time you had the white
lantern that was essentially like
issuing orders like Hal Jordan and
Sinestro and Carol Faye
the star sapphires and essentially
saying you have to find the entities as
it was kind of a way to keep the various
leaders of the lantern course confined
to earth to kind of keep them there
while some may have stray they
ultimately came back and it was designed
to basically bring them all together for
a singular cause and that's really where
this was you know that was really the
basis behind this its fleshing out all
these entities these beings that are
kind of like a representation of the
emotional spectrum now remember they're
not the sum total of the emotional
spectrum like the the bull is not the
sum total of all energy of Rage it's
just the representation of rage it's
kind of one of those interesting
metaphysical things but it does serve
his purpose because one of the things
that happens here is the character of
Atrocitus and this was not necessarily
designed to be a kind of rework of his
character or just to say it wasn't
really like turning the character of
Atrocitus into a hero what it was
designed to do in a lot of ways what's
flesh is character out now the reason I
say that is remember when Atrocitus
first showed up in the green lantern
line of comics he was just a raging
monster in a lot of different ways and
the reason why was because his people
had been totally obliterated by the
Manhunters the robots designed by the
guardians of the universe ah who were
ultimately decommissioned and replaced
with the Green Lantern's to police the
universe but because of that Atrocitus
has always had a hatred for the
guardians of the universe themselves but
he was almost always driven by like rage
and anger but ever since he learned of
the bull basically the entity that
represents rage in the emotional
spectrum
he's been constantly seeking after it
and whether it's because of this sort of
focal point which is to say he can kind
of channel all of his energies and all
of his thoughts into finding this one
thing or if it's because he's been
working alongside Hal Jordan and he's
worked alongside Sinestro he's got other
Lantern Corps members that he's been
working with for whatever reason he's
experiencing a kind of shift of sorts in
the sense that there's basically this
bus full of uh of prisoners and he
effectively kills them all he
annihilates them all in their entirety
and when the question is asked by
Sinestro why would you do this
Atrocitus response is because those who
would take life don't deserve it you
know they basically deserve to lose
there's individuals who would bring harm
or bring pain and suffering to innocent
people don't deserve to live now this is
kind of funny because this does fit into
Atrocitus is not like you know geoff
johns took a huge paradigm shift
Atrocitus is motivation while it was
predicated on the loss of his family and
his desire is to take out the Guardians
and the Green Lantern's it's not just a
desire to kill but for the most part he
believes he'll he'll bring peace to the
universe that if he eliminates the
Guardians
universe if he eliminates the Green
Lanterns these kind of agents for the
guardians schemes and motivations with
what really with Atrocitus knowing a lot
of the things that the Green Lantern's
don't in his mind he's basically
allowing people to live their own lives
outside of the invisible and oftentimes
subtle control of the Guardians
themselves so he's not really a villain
now his actions in terms of attacking
Green Lantern's and killing them things
like that that could be construed as
being villainous depending on how you
view the Green Lantern's and that's
something I want you guys to keep in
mind because as we progress throughout
Geoff Johns run what we're gonna do is
we're gonna start to make this shift
this kind of transition between the
Green Lantern's being just holy good
guys to where we start to look at the
Green Lantern's with a bit of a skewed
eye and especially the guardians of the
universe works like are they really the
heroes that we always thought they were
but at this point we switch back to
Samara and I remember in the last video
we had talked about how the entity that
represents these star sapphires is the
predator and because all these entities
were on earth and because all these
entities it kind of just escaped or at
least people became aware of their
presence following the arrival of the
white lantern what we basically had is
kind of this gold rush for the
respective Lantern course to track down
their entities and Carol Ferris had
effectively come across the predator and
then in turn brought the predator back
to xamarin but the idea was that the
central power battery kind of ran on the
predator more or less but when the
predator had effectively left when that
energy had escaped and the predator had
arrived on earth the belief of the star
sapphires was well it's only a matter of
time of what we use of all the energy in
the central power battery but this is
where Carol Ferris came along and said
that's not true like every other Lantern
core that exists out there the central
power battery the central point by which
you guys as star sapphires derive your
power that's all based on the emotional
aspect of love and so long as there is
love in the universe there will always
be energy in the star sapphire central
power battery and so a depth was the
question became what do we do with the
predator in the dying moments of the
former queen queen agapo of the star
sapphires she had basically made Carol
Ferris the new queen and so what this
means is that Carol Ferris now leaves
the star sapphire but the idea here is
that again what seems to be hinting at
here is that if Carol Ferris may very
well bond with the entity itself that
were not a hundred percent sure about I
mean at this point we're not really
given an answer instead you know she
just kind of takes off with the entity
and when Hal Jordan says when you got to
be back she says when the job is done
which of course is the same answer that
Hal Jordan always gave Carol whenever he
took off but at this point we switch
over to Michigan and we basic
pick up with a young girl and who had
effectively just gone missing it's
basically the idea that Nicole had been
taken captive by some guy but it's
interesting because this girl basically
says I forgive you for the things that
you've done and you know I hope that you
forgive me for what I'm about to do but
I've always been told you have to
forgive those that do wrong and that's
what's so cool about this is because she
immediately topples this guy you know
media you know throws soup Adam and Anna
notice entually tries to make her escape
us of doing but then she's suddenly met
by the arrival of a Dora the Blue
Lantern entity and this is cool
because the way this girl talked when
she said I forgive you for the things
that you've done you know it's very much
Blue Lantern like because it's really
more about like inner peace because it's
really more about finding a kind of
place within yourself where you find a
measure of contentment and you find hope
that's exactly what Nicole's found and
of course she ends up becoming a
becoming a host for a Dora the blue
lantern entity now at this point we
switch back over to Larfleeze and this
is why I say this is where the story
kind of begins to emphasize the nature
of Larfleeze with regards to Hector
Hammond remember when it comes to the
various Lantern cores that are out there
they have a central power battery and a
central power battery is is exactly what
it sounds like it's a giant you know
Lantern more or less in the color of
whatever core represents what the idea
is that is kind of like a consolidation
Factory all the emotion that belongs to
that one particular Lantern core it's
kind of consolidated inside the central
power battery is sort of funneled into
that battery itself or at least a
battery draws on that part of the
emotional spectrum and from there all
that energy is just divvied out among
the various lanterns that exists out
there but remember the amount of energy
any one Lantern can use is essentially
based on how many lanterns are out there
so while there is a lot of energy that's
there one of the things that was
established when it came to you are
flees the orange lantern is that with
the green lanterns you have like 3600
lanterns that are out there and so you
have all this energy split among 3600
people well what happens when you have
that all that energy that goes into one
person that's how it works with
Larfleeze Larfleeze is the orange
lantern the orange lantern of greed of
avarice and so instead of having like a
huge central power battery that anybody
can locate anybody can tap into you
instead it's just his little battery
that he keeps confined to himself and
that'll fit him the orange lantern
entity was confined in now of course
with Hector Hammond consuming that that
lantern all that energy is now in him
and what it means is the power of
Larfleeze is slowly starting to drain
and this is pretty
because as a lantern based on greed he
wants as much as he can possibly have
he's literally just a hoarder and so
because of that when his land when his
Lantern power starts to dissipate it's
crushing because now his self-identity
begins to go away now in truth if the
orange lantern was removed from
Larfleeze for any real measure of time
let's say for like a few weeks or a few
months he would revert back to his
normal state he would no longer be
governed by like greed or anything along
those lines or at least that's that's
how I went interpret I wouldn't think
that would be the case but regardless of
the scenario with his power effectively
waning he's been tasked with kind of
keeping an eye on a guy named Abraham
who is basically the host for the hunted
or entity when it first popped up on
earth before Carol Farris took it to to
Zamora and it is kind of cool here
because what we end up finding out is
that one Larfleeze is not the actual
name of this guy into his family still
alive and they still miss him to a
degree now Larfleeze says for the most
part casts off his former identity he's
basically just become the person he is
now and almost doesn't want to go back
to the person that he was before but it
is kind of cool because when he goes to
attack Abraham of course how Jordan
shows up at Hal Jordan says look we
can't have this you need to calm down
he chill we're here to protect this guy
for you know whatever reason whatever
the motivation is but in the middle of
this conflict they're having their
suddenly met by the arrival of Saint
Walker or at least by a message from
Saint Walker now the funny thing about
this if st. Walker basically grabs them
and says adhara has arrived
adhara has chosen a host now remember
when it comes to a person becoming a
blue lantern that's not something that's
just readily done it's a huge like trial
like you're put through all these trials
and all these tribulations and they
hardcore test your mettle that's why you
don't have 3600 blue lanterns running
around and most you have like five but
the fact that adhara has chosen a host
is very interesting because adhara is
kind of designed to be this sort of
harbinger for how it is the blue
lanterns choose and so if a door has
chosen a host it means a door has
essentially searched throughout all
however many billions of people on earth
and settled on one person the person
best suited to instill hope in others of
course that person being a cult and so
it's awesome because for the blue
lanterns is a time of celebration it's a
time to kind of look around and say this
is what we've been striving for all this
time is to find a dark and then in turn
see if we can't find a way to use that
energy to bolster the power of the blue
lanterns or the very least to find a way
to consolidate that energy into
ourselves so it is kind of cool because
in this moment a door begins to sort of
analyze the various people who were here
she analyzes Larfleeze
for example it says your parents are
still alive and your parents still miss
you why do you choose to live this life
of a you know auras Lantern where you're
so full of like a void a void that can
never truly be filled if you let this go
and you go back to your family you'll
find the life that you've been searching
for it with Hal Jordan is a lot more
interesting you know the ideas that she
analyzes Hal Jordan and says you are
filled with hope but for whatever reason
you won't allow yourself to feel it but
you won't allow yourself to be full of
hope you're afraid of hope why are you
afraid of hope now if I'm gonna be
honest with you guys I would look at hal
jordan i would say he's afraid of hope
because of what could happen how Jordan
at one point was what's hopeful he was a
guy who was full of hope full of
beautiful tomorrows and Leah who knows
what'll happen and who knows what the
future will bring but it will definitely
be brighter than today and then like
coast city was destroyed and then he was
possessed by the parallax entity and
then he wiped out all the green lancers
and killed all the guardians of the
universe except one and then he waged
war against the entirety of the DC
Universe crushed Superman defeated all
the superheroes and tried to blink
reality out of existence and him being
possessed by parallax is predicated on
the idea that he lost what he loved he
lost hope basically and so if he goes
back to being hopeful allowing himself
to care about things again he makes
himself pray for parallax and that's was
kind of interesting because while we end
up having you know Adar who looks to be
like converting house we ran into a blue
lantern suddenly the two of them are
severed the two of them are separated
and the reason why is because they're
met by the arrival of the flash and the
flash simply says we have to talk about
the friends at you're spending time with
we have to talk about the people that
you're keeping company with and we have
to talk about that right now okay so
continuing our discussions on Green
Lantern at this point it's actually
really really cool this is why I love
the Green Lantern tie-in for brightest
day I think it's better than like the
actual main brightest day story but
basically what we do is we pick up with
the rise of parallax slash god flash I
think it's actually really really cool
in terms of how this goes now initially
this picks up with a really with like a
few paramedics really it's kind of like
the aftermath it seems of what went on
with Atrocitus were you know that leader
of the Red Lantern Corps just kind of
went crazy and I killed a bunch of
people stuff like that but it is kind of
interesting because in the middle of all
this they're effectively involved in a
car wreck and where one of them seems to
die they're met by the arrival of the
Indigo tribe now remember when it comes
to the Green Lantern mythos the Indigo
tribe is one of several Lantern cores
that are out there and when it comes to
the various Lantern course one thing to
keep
mine is basically the phrase ROYGBIV red
orange yellow green blue indigo violet
that's the colors of the various lantern
cores that are out there the Indigo
tribe is the most ambiguous it's really
the one that we don't know that much
about and they were designed to be that
way really for a long time it really
wouldn't be until I think after like new
52 the DC actually explained the origins
of the Indigo tribe but they're also
here with the black hand now remember
when it comes to William Han he really
had like his biggest moment well really
had a lot of big moments but he was one
of those characters that Geoff Johns
kind of brought back with regards to the
Green Lantern mythos and then started
rolling him over into like these small
little tidbit cameos he would show up
here he would show up there he'd be a
villain of the flat or I'm sorry of the
Green Lantern for a little while and
then it all basically culminated in the
rise of necron the head of the black
Lantern's basically the Lord of the Dead
quote-unquote or at least one of the
many aspects of death that exists out
there but the idea was that with William
Han because he was obsessed with death
he was kind of like the harbinger for
Necron meaning that he was the one that
basically started kind of expelling
these different rings and kind of
bringing the dead to life and sort of
laying the groundwork for necron showing
up inside the main DC Universe but
following the events of blackest night
William hand found some measure of
redemption that's really what this is
and this says that he just becomes part
of the Indigo tribe now remember this is
the hunt for the various entities that
exists out there these physical
representations of the different aspects
of the emotional spectrum and so when it
comes to the Indigo tribe their entity
is proselyte at least I think that's how
you pronounce it it's basically them
kind of showing up and telling this
paramedic who's really on his deathbed
you know on the moments when he's gonna
die and essentially say you've been
chosen to be the host for proselyte the
entity of the Indigo tribe and so at
this point we switch over to the last
video that we left off that where we
basically had flash throw up a confront
Green Lantern and this is cool because
remember these two go way back I mean
they're they really have an extremely
lengthy history together
and a lot of that goes back to the
events before crisis on Infinite Earths
in the sense that you know they really
kind of like been teammates for quite
some time and so on and so forth they'd
be on the Justice League and they'd
fought together in various team-up
issues and so on and so forth but their
friendship goes back quite a way and the
result is that when it comes to Barry
Allen really showing up on the doorstep
of Hal Jordan the question is why are
you working alongside these other
lanterns and I remember when it comes to
like the Green Lantern Hal Jordan in
terms of how he's perceived by Barry
Allen Barry
has been absent from the DC landscape
for around twenty years and so all he
recalls about how Jordan is the old Hal
Jordan the way he used to be back when
he was a green lantern and it was just
I'm the good guy they're the bad guys
and I never work alongside them now
where the events of blackest night and
the rise of all these black Lantern's
did require the various superheroes to
work alongside all these other Lantern
cores in the eyes of Barry Allen is kind
of like hey look that was like a huge
universe shifting calamity like it was
the end it was the end times like the
end was nigh so we just kind of had to
do what we had to do in order to pull it
all off but at this point Barry Allen's
sort of stance is that blackest night is
over the war the Lantern course doesn't
really exist anymore and so as a result
like there should be no reason why
you're a-lying yourself with these
various Lantern course especially when
you have the head of the Red Lanterns
Atrocitus killing like three busloads of
prisoners there's no reason for you to
be doing this now when the question is
asked why are you out lying yourself
with these guys how Jordan actually
comes back with a pretty reasonable
response where you guys could bring in
telepaths where you guys could bring in
various people that have different
abilities you know impasse and so on and
so forth and where they could track down
these lantern entities at the end of the
day this is kind of in-house and that's
really sort of reminiscent of how DC
treats the Green Lantern for the most
part the Green Lantern is kept kind of
isolated from everything else that's
going on it ties in and it crosses over
but just because you see something in
Green Lantern doesn't mean it's an
absolute it's just so wildly popular or
at least it was at the time this was
being done that the Green Lantern line
of stories were just kind of do it you
want Geoff Johns and you know we won't
really batten I so long as the sales
keep coming in and the stories keep
making you know keep making Bank and so
the result is that it's kind of a Nick
Howard book representation of that
concept in the sense that Green Lantern
here does kind of do whatever he wanted
to but it is interesting because the
idea of of how Jordan is saying look
these entities represent an incredible
level of power and we're keeping this
in-house because we're really the only
ones who are capable of tracking them
adequately and handing them over to
where they need to go and that makes
sense because there's no guarantee that
if Hal Jordan went to the Justice League
and I don't want to bring in like any of
the other Lantern Corps so I need your
help there's no guarantee that justice
lee wouldn't then turn around and say
okay we found parallax time to like put
them in a jar and keep him there forever
there's no guarantee they would be able
to handle it adequately because as far
as Hal Jordan is concerned the Justice
League doesn't truly understand the
emotional spectrum they're not part and
parcel to the emotional spectrum they
the ins and outs of how the whole
Lantern mythos works but how Jordan does
and so it makes sense that with all the
information that's held by the various
Lantern cores that are out there
Sinestro and the yellow answers
Atrocitus and the red lanterns it makes
sense that all that would be kept in
house that who have basically sort of be
isolated from the Justice League
themselves but it's not without merit
and it's not without note because Barry
Allen really kind of feels a measure of
betrayal here where it's kind of like
yeah but like were your friends but for
Hal Jordan it's a lot more personal than
that because while it is kind of kept
in-house the idea is that when it comes
to these entities those individuals who
are possessed by them are basically
being gripped with a level of power they
can't really begin to comprehend and
that's what Hal Jordan brings up he
basically says hey look you were
effectively dead or locked in the Speed
Force or what-have-you but you weren't
here when I was possessed by parallax
when I came home from space you know
from a mission and I found out Co City
had been destroyed that opened the
doorway for parallax to seize hold of me
for fear of losing everybody else I
became this universe level threat I
tried to destroy everything in existence
when it comes to all those things but
how drawer Dhin stance is you weren't
here for all that so you don't
understand the impact that being
possessed by one of these entities has
and so that's what's kind of cool about
this it's because Barry's initial
responses no I'm not going to like I'm
gonna stand here staunchly and we're
gonna find a way to work this out so
again it is kind of interesting now I
would argue in terms of like the way the
Barry Allen's done here it's almost kind
of like making up for lost time right
like trying to be more of a superhero
than he really needs to be it's kind of
like hey look just to show you how good
of a superhero I am we're gonna solve
this together what do you want to or not
but in the middle of all this Barry
basically finds out that is wallet was
stolen by Larfleeze by the orange
lantern of greed again this is why I
love Larfleeze
it's those small little moments here and
there that make things so amazing but
again this is all kind of taking place
with the arrival of Nicole which is to
say the girl who's possessed by the Blue
Lantern entity and so with them having
this debate and having this discussion
they're met by the arrival of the Indigo
tribe now again this is kind of cool
because one of the things is hid out
here and one of the things you seems to
be indicated is that where you have
various Lantern of course out there for
the most part most of the Lantern course
kind of allow you to pick and choose
whether or not you want to wield the
ring for example if you're sitting at
home one day and a Green Lantern ring
pops up and it says you have the ability
to overcome great fear
welcome to the Green Lantern Corps you
can say no and the ring will search for
somebody else
okay cool and it'll go out and it'll
find a different host due to the fact
that you rejected it when it comes to
the Red Lanterns it doesn't work that
way it's basically you know you have
great rage in your heart you belong to
the Red Lantern Corps and it will
forcefully try to bond itself to you one
of the things that's hit out when it
comes to this indigo tribe is they seem
very similar to the star sapphires in
the sense of the Star Sapphire Lantern
Court basically sort of exists to
convert people forcefully the star
sapphires essentially go around and they
say this person has experienced great
love this person has experienced great
loss by extension of the love they felt
and so we are going to basically induct
them into the star sapphires whether
they want to be or not we've seen that
with like the the yellow lanterns for
example right you know I mean during the
whole Sinestro Corps war the star
sapphires grab members of the Sinestro
Corps and then encase them in star
sapphire crystal and try to convert them
for some of them it worked for some of
them that didn't when it comes to this
indigo tribe it almost seems to be very
similar to that in the sense that the
way the indication is given off in terms
of speculation from st. Walker as well
as Nicole herself being possessed by the
you know the blue lantern entity is that
when it comes to William hand how Jordan
stands is just because of the fact that
you found some measure of Redemption by
essentially feeling compassion and being
bonded with a you know an indigo ring
doesn't exonerate you of all the past
crimes that you've committed where
William Hamm basically says yes but I've
been born again you know I've been
baptized in the fires of compassion and
I've come out a new the stance here is
that well maybe it's one of those things
we're like because of the fact that the
blue lantern says none of these people
feel hope maybe it's one of those were
like the the Indigo tribe ring basically
just takes over them it replaces all the
other emotions with nothing but
compassion and so in a sense if you were
to remove that ring what would they turn
into would they go back to their normal
cells and that's the question how Jordan
asks to end a you know indigo one if you
feel compassion by extension of this
ring and this ring effectively forces
you to feel compassion that if I were to
take you and I were to remove you from
the influence of the Indigo tribe what
would you become and so again that's the
whole idea of kind of feeding into the
nature in the the ambiguity of the of
the indigo tribal we'll find out when it
comes to her origin and how it was as
she came to be which is actually pretty
tragic but again it's somewhat cool
because where the groups began coming to
blows in the sense that a fight is
inevitably going to break out just from
all these differing opinions and so on
and so forth they're met by the arrival
of just this mysterious being and this
is just a cloak guys it's kind of an
floating around ever since the the
conclusion of blackest night we don't
know where he's coming from we don't
know what his motivation is all we know
is that this guy's been basically going
around and capturing various entities or
whatever entities he could and so he
effectively shows up here with the
parallax entity and where the initial
response is that is supposed to go for
Hal Jordan what we end up learning is
that it's not instead the parallax
entity is going for the flash Barry
Allen which it possesses and Barry Allen
looks absolutely amazing but basically
it's all the powers of the flash
bolstered by all the energy and all the
evil of parallax himself it's pretty
sweet
all right so continuing on with Green
Lantern Sunday which we've been doing
this for what feels like forever
we have parallax flash versus Hal Jordan
it is managed a sight to behold it's
pretty amazing because as all the powers
of the flash combined with like the
wrath of parallax right like that's
what's so cool about this parallax is
the fear entity like amplifies the
energies of others but for the most part
is just like the representation of fear
but like flash as parallax looks amazing
but notice this this is like a personal
battle between these guys what's so cool
about this is that if you guys you know
when we went over like the secret origin
of Hal Jordan originally in 1993 how
Jordan went crazy after ko city was
destroyed he declared himself parallax
and that was it Geoff Johns came along
and said actually he was possessed by
the parallax entity we just didn't know
it and this was so cool it's because how
Jordan knows parallax like intimately I
mean they know each other in and out
parallax knows what terrifies Hal Jordan
the most but how Jordan knows the
weakness of parallax the problem with
this is that the powers of the flash
come into this and that's what's so cool
is because this is a friend of Barry
Allen I'm sorry friend of Hal Jordan and
that's why parallax possessing one of
the members of the Justice League or
something like that it's such a cool
situation but the conversations between
these two characters and that's what
makes it so interesting the conversation
between these two characters are so
intriguing because one of the things
parallax says is like my ability to
possess area allows me to like
communicate with the Speed Force what
would happen if parallax infiltrated the
Speed Force like if he if he managed to
like corrupted the Speed Force what
would that speed force look like and
that's why things like this are so cool
because it kind of asks these questions
no one ever considered before like
nobody ever thought about before you
know that's what's so interesting about
this like it's just one of these really
cool situations where it's just like man
like 400k for example like nothing to do
with the story I am considering a topic
for a Batman story like I'm trying to
flesh out a Batman story there is a
moment with Alfred we're like if he goes
as planned people are gonna like turn
the page or gonna be like who by God
like there is it's gonna be insane like
what it's gonna be one of those crazy
crazy moments but like that's the kind
of thing like these scenarios that
people never think of that people never
consider that never crosses their mind
that's what makes these stories so cool
but for parallax it's not just you're a
character they're like you're a person
that I'm fighting if you are Hal Jordan
like I want you back because remember
parallax was brought here you know that
mysterious short Guardian person the
first thing we have no idea who it is at
the moment we know it is now in real
life but like living in the immersion we
don't know who that person is and in
that instance with parallax showing up
like wanting to repossess Hal Jordan
it's so cool because it's like this is
where I belong like I belong in Hal
Jordan like that's where I'm supposed to
be and it's cool because parallax exists
to spread fear that's all it is and when
Hal Jordan was possessed by parallax he
tried to blink the universe out of
existence and bring it back during zero
hour crisis in time the closest parallax
ever got to spreading fear across the
cosmos I would say the peak of him was
when he possessed Hal Jordan and so it
makes the most sense that he would want
to go back and possess Hal Jordan again
and that's all this really is it's the
whole whole idea of like I want to
repossess you and how Jordan finally
picks up on that
how do orden finally realizes that like
you want to possess me so then possess
me and initially parallax goes to do
that but this Guardian jumps in the way
well this is this person jumps all the
way he says he's not a guardian but you
know he jumps of the waves as parallax
stop you are not here to attack Hal
Jordan you're not here to possess him or
anything like that you're here to do my
bidding you are here to do a job that I
have that I've assigned you to and when
the intention of this is of this
guardian guy is to destroy Hal Jordan
suddenly we end up having like all these
Lantern Corps start jumping in you have
like the Indigo tribe you have the blue
lanterns you have Larfleeze that shows
up it's cool because remember while this
whole thing is going on everyone's
hunting for the entities a lot of them
have already been found but everyone's
hunting for all the others they're
trying to locate them and trying to
figure out where they're at but at this
point we switch over to out - Sinestro
and - Atrocitus you remember they're on
the hunt for the butcher which is the
Red Lantern entity and the funny thing
about this is that Sinestro is going ill
aligned himself with Atrocitus for no
other reason than the fact that like hey
look maybe somebody worse than
we'll get the get the entities and
that's a problem so like I'd rather he
you know on the devil's right-hand then
in his path and so we are going to allow
ourselves of Atrocitus and do what we
need to do the problem with this is that
Romar to one of the yellow lanterns
comic kind of calls him up it says hey
man
the webinar that major yellow answered
ring originally he's got your daughter
on court because remember cirrhotic not
who she bailed out on the lantern course
and like took off left and went to go be
her own lantern and so the result is at
this point in time she's sitting you
know in court she's sitting in the
antimatter universe and then like this
guy's like hey man this guy demands your
presence and it's like all right look
that's that's probably the worst thing
you could have said was like my presence
is demanded because the coolest thing
about Sinestro more than like how he
fights how Jordan more than him creating
his own Lantern Corps all the kind of
stuff is his arrogance like he's one of
those characters were like no way on dig
arrogance but like for me like you look
at Sinestro and it's like yeah man like
he's arrogant and really cocky and it's
amazing like it's it's so cool because
like he's one of the characters like
like I don't know many of you guys those
are guys who are not not like Lantern
fans if you're stumbling across this
video there are people love Sinestro
like they are huge fans of Sinestro
actually I'm curious now that we say it
who was your favorite Lantern like who's
your favorite Lantern of all the
lanterns that exists out there I don't
care about the course who is your
favorite Lantern like is it how Jordan
is a Barry Allen you know I guess when
he was a Blue Lantern is it you know
Atrocitus as the Red Lanterns like
posted let me know because I'm I'm
really kind of curious but this is
intriguing because in the middle of all
this we end up having this Guardian just
kind of show up and when the question is
asked like who are you and why are you
here initially he doesn't answer you
know it's it's kind of intriguing
because one of the things that happened
here was that this Guardian sort of
taking off was done at the hand of
Larfleeze right like Marv Lee's is the
orange lantern remember when it comes to
all the other Lantern Corps Green
Lantern's in the Indigo tribe in the
blue lanterns and yadda yadda yadda and
so on you have the emotion of Hope or
rage or what-have-you that spread across
all these individuals with Lars it's not
like that it channels directly into him
meaning he has the power of a thousand
lanterns and that's what this does the
guy conjures a construct this saw it
like this massive construct and just
smashes the Guardian with it and it's so
cool because initially Hal Jordan you
know contacts the blue lanterns contacts
st. Walker's to say look man I need your
help man like things are popping off
everything's starting to go crazy and
then like here comes Larfleeze out of
nowhere like out up dude RKO and nowhere
just like smashes this guy and it's the
coolest thing because it's just like too
and this is this is why it's so cool to
me because like when I read this
originally it was my first time reading
it it was probably like seven months ago
was my first time reading it and like
I'm seeing this stuff that people have
known for years and it's just like this
is what you guys have been reading I've
been missing out man but it's so
interesting because what this Guardian
does is he pops back up onto the scene
and says you guys have served your
purpose this was all part of the plan
you didn't defeat me he does somehow
swindle me into a trap like you've done
everything that I wanted you to do and
what I wanted you to do was take every
single person who is possessed by an
entity and locate them in one place
because in turn what he does is snatch
the entities out of every single one of
those guys so this one person is now in
possession of all the lantern entities
that we've discovered so far and the
result is that when the question is
asked yet again who are you like why are
you here we end up finding out that this
guy stands apart from the guardians of
the of the universe he's not one of them
but he was at one point in time this guy
is Crona and this is cool
do you know the Guardian that looked
back at the beginning of everything and
witnessed the creation of the universe
and set the entirety of the Lantern
Corps and really like good and evil the
whole nine yards set it all in motion
this guy is the one who's responsible
for the creation of the multiverse
notice this though this is something I
want you guys to really really notice
here there's the hand in the window
that's that's old that's best old school
content that's back in today that's a G
double og content that is back in like
the secret origin really even way back
then you know when when when when crisis
on Infinite Earths happen is when that
was revealed but that hand right there
I still say to this day that's the hand
of dr. Manhattan that's the hand about
Manhattan creating the entirety of the
universe I say he made it man I say dr.
Manhattan made the universe I'm gonna
stick with that until DC releases the
story and we find out he didn't but I'm
very sure he did in which case now we
got to call him papa Manhattan we got a
call like okay Papa Manhattan like like
whatever you want us to do man like we
all clean our room but it's cool like
this this is a great story like this is
why I love this stuff so much this Green
Lantern stuff why geoff johns is is just
criminally good i mean it's it's it's
stupid how good it is and how
interesting it all comes together okay
so picking back up with the Green
Lantern brightest day we pick up with
the Red Lantern god of the red lantern
entity I like calling them Red Lantern
gods
I think there's I think
think calling them gods are kind of cool
but technically there are entities um
but again you know it's actually been a
couple of weeks of course you know we
had like Emerald City Comicon and then I
came down with a really with like a
really bad bout of food poisoning and so
on but we're back into the swing of
things so of course we'll have this and
we'll have x-men that comes out later on
today but for those of you guys who are
who have forgotten a little bit about
what we talked about or who aren't
really caught up or who are new here to
my channel the idea is that you have
these entities and that that's really
what's taking place in this is that
somebody's rounding up the entities the
the general gist or at least what was
told to us at the end of blackest night
was that life on Earth is really where
like all life began and so the various
entities represent these parts of the
emotional spectrum you know like fear
and rage and greed and different things
like that and that these all just sort
of coalesce and came into existence you
know rage for example came into
existence the first time that like an
organism killed another organism on
earth out of rage and like fear happened
you know fear came into existence the
first time that the first organism on
earth felt fear this is the kind of
thing that took place like over the
course of like all life across the
cosmos this is how these things began to
grow and how these um these parts the
emotional spectrum began to expand now
what we also knew or at least what we
were we were told anyway is that all
these lantern entities existed on earth
we just didn't know where and in fact
this was a new thing by Geoff Johns we
knew that like parallax was the entity
or letting on the God so to speak for
the for the yellow Lantern Corps but
parallax had long since been established
in DC Comics and so that wasn't a very
new thing but the other entities
cropping up here this was all basically
fleshed out by John Sibley saying like
they all arrived here on earth and
Atrocitus the head of the Red Lantern
Corps is basically looking for the
butcher which is the Red Lantern entity
because of the fact that Atrocitus being
able to locate the things he wants
really locating the entity itself
requires a sacrifice of blood basically
what he does is he kills people but
again this is one of the things we've
talked about in the previous videos but
Atrocitus is very much a conflicted
character he's very much a character
who's stuck in this interesting position
because he's not really like a villain I
mean he is a villain in the traditional
sense you know and the idea that like he
commits terrible things but his
motivation is to take out the guardians
of the Green Lantern's but he does value
innocent life and in fact we're gonna
see how far his conviction goes in this
particular story but basically one of
the first things he does is kill a
couple people in cop cars as well the
first thing he does is kill people and
then of course basically you know try to
locate
where the butcher is at where the Red
Lantern entity is now from here we
switch over to a guy by the name of
Joshua Hayes and Joshua Hayes is
basically a guy here who stands
convicted for the murder of a young girl
and what he ends up doing is actually
taunting the father which is pretty
sadistic now again these entities go
after individuals who basically imbue
what it is they stand for so in this
instance what is it happening is a guy
named James is actually tormenting this
guy I guess uh I'm sorry Joshua's
tormenting this guy James James being
the father of the scroll Elizabeth who
was killed and where Joshua basically
gives him a hard time and you know does
everything he can to to basically drive
this guy up the wall to kind of drive
him nuts there suddenly met with the
arrival of the butcher who comes showing
up and really in no uncertain terms just
kind of comes smashing through a wall
but where we would expect that Joshua
would be the one who would be possessed
because he was just so evil so
vindictive so full of rage and so full
of anger the rage of the father of
Elizabeth actually Trump's that and
that's why this is cool again this is
the idea of Jeff John's writing Green
Lantern is it ties in like these
emotional themes you know no pun
intended with the overall idea of the
Green Lantern mythos it ties in like
these emotional themes these convictions
that these people are really just
genuinely filled with rage and the
butcher goes after James now in the
middle of all this really when this
starts to happen this Spectre suddenly
shows up now here's the funny thing
about this The Spectre and the butcher
at least in terms of this immediate
situation almost seemed to represent the
same thing the butcher represents like
rage and vengeance really rage more so
than vengeance but like in this instance
the butcher is possessing James because
James is so filled with rage and in turn
it would allow James to get vengeance on
Joshua for killing his daughter but the
spectre is the living embodiment of
God's vengeance it's almost as though
the The Spectre is kind of in this
position of look you're encroaching on
my territory now the spectre knows about
the butcher and he has known it for
quite some time we found that out in
blackest night but it is intriguing
because what ends up happening is the
The Spectre actually sort of starts to
fight with the butcher and actually try
to destroy the entity I remember these
entities can be destroyed I mean they're
not immutable forces it's not like you
know if you destroy them though they'll
come back or something along those lines
they're basically gone once they're dead
but the fact remains here with this
particular scenario this is where the
things sort of share a common ground in
the sense that the butcher is is
essentially like in this massive fight
with with the specter and again it is it
is pretty interesting you miss kind of
cool but then suddenly you have the
Atrocitus now again Atrocitus isn't
really here to pick a fight with the
spectre himself at all honesty I haven't
really read of an instance where like
Atrocitus and the spectre have fought in
terms of the spectre in his current form
and Atrocitus in his current form
it's not to say that fight doesn't exist
it's something that I haven't read it
yet so I mean it may be further on down
the line in the Green Lantern mythos or
so we just part of a story that I
haven't that I haven't caught up with
yet I would probably argue that
Atrocitus wouldn't win against the
spectre but maybe he will you know maybe
he does again I'm not gonna swear to
that I couldn't take it as an absolute
but again you know the butcher basically
possessing James actually sees James
take on this pretty wicked form and
again that's par for the course that's
what we've seen with the lantern
entities when the entities possess a
living house that living host goes on to
basically take on a kind of humanoid
form representative of like whatever it
is that Lantern entity stands for as
well as something that just absolutely
looks boss and like James looks like a
beast like it's it's pretty solid to see
him in this form but the spectre kind of
has this sort of internal model or at
least a discussion of sources with James
you know with with the role they play
even with Atrocitus himself because of
the fact that the spectre is the living
embodiment of vengeance the spectre
kills regularly that's the role it's
surf's i mean it's it was designed for
the purpose of killing things but in the
spectres mind the role that it plays is
different from this particular role with
James being possessed by the Red Lantern
entity James is possessed by an entity
that's been on rage
James is looking for vengeance and so
the lantern entity takes possession of
James and then James seeks vengeance for
the spectre the role he plays is a
divine role a particular role he plays
in the universe it's not a position he's
thrust himself into the Spectre was
created by God for that purpose so again
it's kind of one of these things of the
natural order of things versus the
unnatural order of things and so what is
it happening of courses is the spectre
is basically attacked by James as a Red
Lantern entity which looks awesome and
then in turn James basically kills
Joshua and that's really the end of
Joshua but from there Atrocitus steps in
and Atrocitus actually destroys this
physical form basically rips away the
shell of sorts and then basically frees
like the butcher from the body of James
and it's kind of cool because the
butcher could easily just kind of
restructure itself or kind of bring this
body back or what-have-you but the
butcher actually looks at Atrocitus and
says well let's see what's what rages in
your heart
I have no need to possess James anymore
because he's gotten the vengeance that
he seeks he has a feel rage anymore and
if that rage is gone then there's no
reason for me to possess him and so the
result is that when it looks at
Atrocitus we give it you know a quick
little three-panel
bit of his origin which again you're
welcome to check out the full-on origin
of Atrocitus to really gain a huge
understanding of what's going on but of
course you know you have the specter
step in inspector basically disables the
disables the butcher temporarily long
enough for Atrocitus to seek control of
it now this is when things get pretty
cool because when Atrocitus imprisons
the butcher inside of his own ax his own
lantern battery from their this specter
goes to destroy James because this is
the world of the Spectre place
James has basically sought vengeance and
taken an innocent life now the fact that
he was possessed by the bull is
irrelevant here James would have killed
Joshua had he been given the chance
regardless of whether he was possessed
or not and that's the distinct
difference that's the difference between
the the spectre who would just kind of
walk away and the spectre who would take
out James have the bull possessed James
and then driven James to kill Joshua
that would have been a whole different
set of events it would have been a
decision that James didn't want to make
but was forced to but because James did
this the spectre intends to destroy him
and this is where I say we get into this
cool motivation about Atrocitus because
Atrocitus steps in and says this is
fallacy this is actually you know
absolute nonsense sure James wanted to
kill this guy but James had every reason
to kill this guy now this is where
things get a little hairy and a little
ambiguous because for the Spectre
there's there's no real gray area there
there's no black and white there's no
ambiguity you are a person who committed
a terrible deed and so you are a person
who has to go done that's it with
Atrocitus it's it's kind of like this
idea that Atrocitus it's Nana says well
I understand humanity better than you do
but it's not a human factor it is a
sentient living breathing emotion
feeling organism kind of thing The
Spectre is just sort of an idea a
concept that Bond's itself to any one
particular being in order to serve its
purpose and even the Spectre is NaN
Kapoor didn't have to actually be you
know be bond to someone think you just
kind of flowed out there but the
spectres usually always bonded to
someone and it's always kind of cool to
see that that kind of thing happened but
Atrocitus basically says like look
you've been bonded to living host to
human host
since really since like you the earliest
days of your existence and you still
don't grasp them because a Spectre is
not designed to the spectres not
designed to really understand humanity I
guess to a degree it is and the sense of
like that's why it's bonding to host but
it's never understood humanity watch
Serrano says this is the nature of
beings people love people hate people
fall into all these different emotional
categories
James desire to kill Joshua was not
based on the fact that Joshua stole
money it wasn't based on the fact that
Joshua like you know offended him or the
woman he was with it was because Joshua
killed his daughter what father wouldn't
want to kill the man who killed his
daughter that's just the reasonable
thing to do and that's that's how
anybody would normally respond it makes
sense and so again like you know the The
Spectre sort of says okay fine then like
you know if that's how you want to be
then where do we go from here and
Atrocitus says if you want to judge him
you have to judge me first and so the
spectre does and the Spectre backs off
and it's cool because the Spectre simply
says this war that you're involved in
right now like you believe that all
you've wanted to do is capture the
butcher and everybody that you've teamed
up with with Sinestro and Hal Jordan and
Carol Farris and so on you simply see
this as a means to an end to get the
butcher and go about your business but
know that you're on a collision course
that Crona the the Guardian that
basically set in motion the creation of
them of the multiverse the original
guardian that was cast out that he's
very much alive and well and you are
involved in this war with him whether
you want to be or not and so your war
against Crona is effectively a holy war
it is a war you have to be a part of but
when this war ends the time will come
when I will arrive and I will judge you
and when I do I will destroy you now
we'll actually have to kind of wait and
you'll look into the future to see
whether or not that happens but again it
is cool and it is intriguing because
before Atrocitus who gives us this
monologue of saying he hates humanity he
hates humans he's so much like a human
he's so much like a regular normal
but again this is the unique principle
of Atrocitus because among all the Red
Lanterns with him being the one that
created the court he's the only one
that's really able to maintain his
autonomy I mean when someone's forced
him to the Red Lantern Corps like they
basically lose their minds they're kind
of mindless beasts for the most part is
really kind of how they function and it
and it serves his purpose because
there's sort of cutting a swath through
the universe attacking all these
different things and it's cool to just
see them rage out like that but it is it
is interesting and I really like it in
terms of how this whole thing unfolds
and what it does and so on and so forth
but anyway guys just a quick little
one-shot story ah this will lead
directly into the war of the Green
Lantern's the the war with Cronus so
we're basically moving into the next
story arc beyond brightest day but with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you are new here
to comments explained make sure you guys
have the sub
become part of the rod core if you guys
enjoy this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
please
[Music]
you